a wrinkle in time was directed by Ava
Duvernay and is a story of young Meg who
loses her scientist father played by
Chris Pine he disappears no one knows
where he is he was experimenting with
this strange idea he had that you could
bend the universe in travel light-years
in seconds and he vanished and he's been
gone for a long time and when three
strange beings arrived in her backyard
mrs. which mrs. whatsit and mrs. who
meg her brother and friend go off on an
adventure through time and space to try
to find her father I'm a fan of Ava
Duvernay I think she's brilliant if you
saw Selma you know that or xiii a very
searing documentary that's on Netflix
about racial prejudice in the prison
system she is great and she brings a lot
to the table and some things to the
table that don't really work this is a
visually stunning film sometimes
sometimes it is also fairly horrible
looking there's no escaping it some of
the special effects in green-screen are
extremely noticeable and they're not
quite as impressive as I think this film
thinks they are especially for a Disney
production some of the visuals are
stunning some of the real onset
locations they shot in in New Zealand
the countryside's really gorgeous stuff
there's a sequence with flowers that are
like gossipers where the flowers fly up
and tell rumors about things they've
seen that's one of the best sequences in
the film but there's also a lot of very
odd special effects that don't always
work like a literal giant Oprah Winfrey
showing up in Meg's backyard
she didn't Tess her as they call it
correctly and now she's really big in
Meg's backyard and Meg is just kind of
looking at this godzilla-sized
Oprah Winfrey and her reaction is kind
of like huh well that's that's kind of
strange Meg seems more surprised when
Reese Witherspoon is able to turn around
in circles and change her outfit and
then become something else which is also
very surprising but I mean a giant Oprah
Winfrey is also that's pretty startling
I'd say if I saw that in my backyard I
my pants I'd be like hey
I really liked your interview with
Michael Jackson you're a lot taller in
person there are some very touching
scenes most of them involving this
family in the opening you really do feel
a sense of warmth in their household and
when her father disappears I felt really
bad for her it was captured very
authentically but the interim from first
act to third act is so jumbled it's so
messy it reminded me of a film called
lady in the water I've always respected
lady in the water it's not one of sha
Milan's best films a lot of critics
called it one of the worst films ever
made but it was an original film based
off of Shama long's bedtime story it
wasn't based off of anything else and it
was also similar to a wrinkle in time
one of those everything but the kitchen
sink movies that kind of just throws
everything at the screen sees what
sticks and I will always respect a
filmmaker like Shyamalan or Ava Duvernay
who does not play it safe who makes a
film that's very odd that a lot of
people won't like and I do respect Ava
Duvernay for that but that doesn't mean
the films any good it's a very very
disappointing film it didn't really feel
like it had a human touch after the
first act it was just a lot of really
Wow
sequences that didn't really land with
the type of punch I think they wanted
them to know I don't like to be too
critical of child performances and films
but I am critical when an adult
filmmaker relies quite heavily and quite
especially on the performance of a young
person now storm reed who plays meg is
fairly good in this movie especially in
some of the more emotional scenes she
doesn't really show a lot of surprise
when these awe-inspiring things are
happening before her eyes which was a
little strange to me but she is very
good as an awkward young girl who is not
comfortable with her own self yet it's
one of the major themes of the film and
a lot of kids will learn good things
from that but her younger brother
Charles Wallace is the character mm-hmm
didn't work for me I thought he was very
bad in the film and I feel bad saying
that but I didn't the film relies quite
a bit on him and there's a lot of really
head
close ups especially toward the third
act and I didn't think it worked there
is a chance that young kids today will
see this movie and it will be like their
hook critics saw hook in 91 and hated it
kids from that era loved it this could
be this kid generations hook for all we
know but it reminded me of lady in the
water a film that I respected but was
very messy I'm gonna give a wrinkle in
time a c-minus
this was disappointing I really wanted
to like this film but it just didn't
work for me I'm curious to see what Ava
Duvernay does next because I think she's
great and a lot of this cast is also
great but this film was just
discombobulated guys thank you very much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon and if you like
this you can click right here and get
steppen iced
[Music]